so you have worked with a lot of great
artists um and you've worked with a lot
of great artists on the album which I
love both
um you've worked with Snoop that's
satellite which is so good thank you
it's one of my favorites I love
satellite I love this man too like I
want to tell the story of like how I hit
him up and like this how the song came
about that's what I was gonna ask you
like how did how did you call him I I
okay so like usually a lot of times you
go through management or you go through
like the label or whatever but I am like
I've always been a hustler and I feel
like you have to always kind of hustle
to like make things happen yourself
sometimes yeah yeah so I went on this I
went on Instagram and
um I was like let me just send him a
message oh my God you did not I love
this yeah and I said hey I have a song I
would love to send it to you if you like
it I would love to for you to like wrap
on it or what do your thing if not
totally fine I won't I won't take it you
know I want you to really like it and
then he called me the next morning at 7
00 a.m with a blunt and his mouth sure
and he like smoked and he like blew the
smoke to the phone and he's like check
your email and I was like
I love that it's so good it's one of my
favorite songs I got like chills this I
was like this is such a great yeah I
love saddle it's saddle it's called
satellite with Snoop it's it's one of my
favorite songs on the album higher than
a satellite come on yeah I was like well
we were really inspired I was really
inspired by by Elton John Rocket Man I
just yeah yeah I didn't know what that
song was about I don't think I did when
I was younger either most songs I was
saying yeah exactly that are like highly
inappropriate but I don't know right
remember that remember this song you're
going over the counter I have no idea
you're singing that so loud and loving
that song and not knowing what it was
I'm older than you and I was singing Red
Light Special by TLC
oh that's so inappropriate for like a 12
year old oh yeah yeah but I had no idea
what I was singing But I just love this
song I was like give me the Red Light
Special and I'm like what I was like
what it's so gross
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]